i
[Música]
ah
y aquí
[Música]
yo llegué a colombia un lunes 17 de
abril del 2017 si a mí me preguntan a
qué horas llegué yo rápidamente dijo a
las 9 y 30 de la mañana ahora si me
preguntan a qué horas nací que es un
dato que necesitaba veces jamás lo he
podido retener en mi memoria
yo serví de venezuela sola mi hijo que
parece entonces tenía 26 años decidió
quedarse entre mis planes nunca estuvo
el salir de mi país sin embargo a veces
la vida nos lleva a unas situaciones
donde tenemos que tomar decisiones muy
por encima de nuestra propia voluntad en
ese momento mi única opción era emigrar
cuando uno internaliza esa decisión la
vida comienza a sumergirse en un
profundo dolor porque uno no sabe si
realmente va a volver a ver a esos seres
que está dejando atrás
cuando uno llega al país de destino ese
dolor se intensifica aún más y eso es lo
que los expertos denominan el duelo
migratorio ellos lo definen como el
dolor que está asociado a la pérdida que
genera el hecho de emigrar
si a mí me preguntan que es el duelo
migratorio siempre digo que es aprender
a vivir con un frío en el alma que nos
acompaña de manera permanente
los especialistas dicen que este duelo
tiene cuatro etapas y siete duelos que
superar no 17 y de allí lo complejo de
este proceso
la primera etapa es el descubrimiento en
ella estamos asombrados y distraídos con
todo lo novedoso que nos muestra la
ciudad donde estamos la segunda es la
negación es la etapa más difícil más
larga porque allí empezamos a
cuestionarnos todo surgen las culpas y
comparamos todo el tiempo absolutamente
todo la tercera es la aceptación y es un
momento donde uno se rinde ante tanto
dolor pero esa rendición no es
entregarse esa rendición significa
enfrentar ese dolor y aprender algo de
él porque siempre detrás del dolor hay
un aprendizaje cuando lo logramos
identificar entonces podemos aceptar
nuestra realidad desde otra perspectiva
la cuarta etapa es el desapego
y en un proceso que considero sumamente
valioso para el ser humano porque es
liberador es en ese momento como cuando
logramos quitar esas cadenas que nos ata
y nos estanca desde ese entonces podemos
surgir y fluir con la vida
en estas cuatro etapas los duelos se van
presentando de manera intermitente hay
siete duelos que son el duelo a la
familia a los amigos el duelo a lo que
fue el duelo a la gastronomía al paisaje
a la cultura la lengua y a lo material
cada persona vive este proceso de manera
distinta y a cada quien le afectan unos
duelos más que otros a mí me costó
superar mucho el duelo a la familia y a
los amigos y el duelo a quien fui
generalmente este proceso se aborda
siempre desde el dolor pero yo quiero en
esta oportunidad abordarlo desde lo
enriquecedor que es porque está lleno de
muchísimo aprendizaje que además es un
proceso obligado para poder salir de
manera exitosa de este proceso en mi
experiencia
el duelo me ha permitido aprender a
identificar cinco herramientas que me
han ayudado a afrontarlo y poder estar
hoy aquí en medellín después de tres
años la primera herramienta es el
enfoque hay dos maneras de emigrar una
cuando yo emigro pensando que en ese
país donde voy me van a dar la ayuda que
perdí en mi país desde esa perspectiva
proyecto necesidad y lo que recibo son
ayudas momentáneas que no permiten
generar estabilidad el otro es cuando yo
emigro pensando que en ese país voy a
permitirme construir oportunidades a
través de mis capacidades
desde allí entonces puedo ayudar a
contribuir y aportar en la sociedad
donde llegó desde este enfoque hemos
emigrado muchísimos venezolanos la
segunda herramienta es la red de apoyo
difícilmente un ser humano puede vivir
aislado y menos en un país que no conoce
por eso es fundamental crear vínculos
con las personas que tenemos en el
entorno porque a partir de allí podemos
recibir no solamente ese esa mano amiga
en los momentos difíciles sino que con
ellos también surgen grandes
oportunidades además de darnos a conocer
nosotros como personas y también poder
ayudar la tercera herramienta es el
propósito y esto tiene que ser una
herramienta que nos dé la fuerza pero
que salga desde el corazón porque es lo
que necesitamos para poder levantarnos
cada mañana y seguir adelante en lo
personal tenía dos propósitos el primero
era esforzarme cada vez más porque yo
sabía que en algún momento iba a llegar
esa llamada de venezuela- que me iba a
decir
mamá me voy a colombia y en ese momento
yo quería tener mejores condiciones para
darle la oportunidad a mi hijo de pensar
que aún hay esperanzas para crear futuro
y el segundo tiene que ver con algo que
yo traía conmigo desde que salí de
venezuela y era querer ayudar a los
venezolanos donde quiera que estuviera
por dos razones una porque es para mí la
manera de agradecerle a mi país todo lo
que me dio y segundo porque sigo
pensando que es la única forma que tengo
para ayudar desde esa red que yo
construí y con mi propósito hoy soy
parte de dos organizaciones que
trabajamos en pro de los de los
venezolanos pero además ayudamos a los
retornados colombianos y a los amigos de
medellín que viven en esos sectores
vulnerables donde está nuestra población
eso a mí me llena de satisfacción
la cuarta herramienta es la actitud en
el entorno de los migrantes es muy común
escuchar lo perdí todo y tengo que
empezar de cero cualquiera dice
yo no lo creo porque yo no perdí todo en
venezuela yo traigo conmigo esas
herramientas que pude aprender que pude
desarrollar mis talentos mis habilidades
y esas son las herramientas que me
acompañan a mí en el transcurso de la
vida y con lo que yo puedo llegar a
cualquier sitio a salir adelante una de
las herramientas que yo pensaba que me
podía ayudar a estabilizar rápido en
colombia' era mi título profesional
sin embargo cuando llegue el primer
empleo que obtuve fue entregar volante
en un semáforo en una campaña de moto
esa noche antes de empezar por mi mente
pasaban muchas cosas y me preguntaba
cómo es posible que yo con un título de
pregrado y una maestría lo único que
tenía era entregar volante en un
semáforo al otro día cuando me levanté
salí a trabajar con la misma actitud
como si fuera a trabajar en mi oficina
pero además de eso luego trabajé como
mesera una noche con unas amigas
limpiando una oficina en una óptica
cuidando una niña que nunca hablaba
español y todo eso entonces me enseñó a
entender que no somos títulos no somos
etiquetas somos seres humanos que vamos
desarrollando habilidades capacidades y
con eso es que nosotros siempre vamos a
poder salir adelante porque eso es lo
que tenemos como personas
la quinta herramienta es la resiliencia
que no es más sino podernos adaptar a
los cambios que estamos viviendo pero
además es arriesgarse a transformarnos
como personas a reinventarnos porque es
desde allí como nosotros vamos a
aprender a ir adaptándonos a todos los
procesos de cambio que nos genera la
vida
de todas estas herramientas además mi
proceso del duelo me dio un gran
aprendizaje y es desprenderme de lo que
fui y enfocarme en quién soy porque solo
así yo puedo conseguir la fortaleza y
demostrarme de lo que soy capaz para
fluir en la vida donde quiera que esté
muchas gracias
[Música]